[Musica]
allora io sono un architetto e insegno
all'università i ragazzi a progettare di
progetti ovviamente ne ho fatti tanti e
nel corso del tempo ho pensato che si
potrebbero riunire in tre categorie
i primi sono quelli che sogni di fare
che desideri da sempre che quando ti
capitano veramente rappresentano un po
una realizzazione altri sono quelli che
ti capitano e un po perché come
architetti guadagna veramente poco un po
perché anche come professori
universitari non è che stiamo molto bene
allora gli accetti di buon grado sempre
e comunque
e poi c'è la terza categoria che è
quella dei progetti invece che ti
capitano nel loro ricercano le tue i
cerchi sono cose che succedono
la storia di oggi riguarda questa terza
categoria
un giorno mio amico economista mi chiama
e mi dice chiara ti vorrei dare una
fregatura gli dico guarda che la sola
già me l'hai data sola vuol dire
fregatura il romano perché qualche tempo
prima abbiamo fatto fare uno dei lavori
più belli che io abbia mai fatto ma
canta una delle persone più
insopportabili con le quali io abbia mai
lavorato e dare una donna
ovviamente però mi ha incuriosito perché
mi ha detto questa volta ti voglio
presentare tarzan e allora la curiosità
è femmina io sono andata a conoscere
tarzan e sono entrata in una realtà che
è un po da borghesuccia quali sono
sempre visto con gli occhi negativi che
è quella delle occupazioni e delle
occupazioni negli edifici pubblici che
ritornano ad essere beni comuni ma
procediamo per gradi
allora abbiamo calamità naturali stanno
battendo anche il nostro paese abbiamo
terrorismo che come dice il papa ha
portato la terza guerra mondiale e sta
invadendo tutto il globo e tutti queste
problematiche stanno portando centinaia
di migliaia se non milioni di persone a
riversarsi in altri paesi molte sono
quelle che vanno nel continente europeo
lo sappiamo
molte sono quelle che arrivano nel
nostro paese e quelle che non sono in
transito sono già 5 milioni 5 milioni di
residenti stranieri provenienti da gran
parte delle coste del mediterraneo ma
anche da asia e sud america
questo problema porta ovviamente ha una
necessità di dare una risposta per dove
far vivere abitare queste persone
una risposta che è molto difficile da
trovare perché c'è una stasi
istituzionale come diceva
l'anticipazione cioè il nostro stato
politicamente non sta reagendo a questo
problema
e allora qual è la risposta che le
persone autonomamente vanno cercando
le risposte informali catania bologna
milano bergamo sono tutte città che
hanno problematiche di questo tipo
palermo ancora qualunque lingua a un
modo per definire questi luoghi
baraccopoli in italiano ma bidonville
slam favelas di gas e anche roma è una
delle città che è invasa da questo ora
in italia in particolare a roma direi
ancora di più questo problema si acuisce
perché questi slam vanno a intaccare la
grande bellezza questo acquedotto che
l'acquedotto appio claudio che noi
vediamo dietro le spalle di toni
servillo el'acquedotto nei cui fornici
facevo vedere le baracche di prima
70.000 le persone al 2011 che
dichiaravano di vivere in insediamenti
informali in italia ma più di 70.000
2014 le persone sfrattate per morosità
all'altro problema dell'emergenza casa
cioè la crisi economica e 650 mila le
persone che ancora stanno in lista di
attesa per una casa popolare perché la
casa popolare sparita quello che è stato
un po il successo degli architetti gli
anni 50 60 poi 70 e 80 c ai grandi
insediamenti che sono stati realizzati
in quell'epoca si sono arrestati il 4
per cento di tutto il patrimonio
immobiliare e rappresenta italiano
residenziale è rappresentato da case
popolari ma e dà alloggio 500mila
persone 650.000 stanno aspettando
in parallelo cambia la nostra demografia
ricorderete il film del 1987 di ettore
scola la famiglia in cui questa
grandissima famiglia allargata vista nel
corso del novecento va pian piano
smembrando se nel suo numero di persone
e quelle case che abitavano prima i
nonni con le sorelle zitelle con i figli
con i figli dei figli cominciano ad
essere vuote ecco la nostra demografia e
cambiata la famiglia tradizionale che
rappresenta tuttavia il 34 per cento
della nostra società
in realtà è formata da genitori e figli
e molti sono le famiglie rappresentate
dai genitori separati con figli
divorziati o anche genitori che scelgono
di fare i figli da soli quindi sempre
monoparentali gli anziani vivono per
conto loro non più con i figli ei figli
dei figli è l'unica famiglia che è un po
può rappresentare
diciamo adattarsi meglio alle dimensioni
dei nostri grandi appartamenti e quella
multietnica e quella straniera che
ancora quella che riesce a vivere in una
comunità più allargata 20 per cento le
giovani coppie che non investono nei
mutui e tanto meno e non far i figli per
l'incertezza economica nella quale ci
troviamo
e infine il dato più interessante è
quello dei single 34 per cento come le
famiglie tradizionali 34 per cento di
studenti city users walker cioè
praticamente nomadi digitali persone che
girano nelle città ci vivono sei mesi un
anno qualche settimana in cerca di
contaminazioni dai con sistemi diversi e
quindi persone che stanno modificando
fortemente in stili di vita a cui siamo
abituati e quindi di conseguenza cambia
l'ambito domestico perché non c'è più il
pranzo della domenica tutti insieme ma
si mangiano pasti frugali davanti al
computer spesso in ufficio e non c'è più
quel rito bellissimo che io ricordo bene
che era vedere il carosello prima di
andare a dormire quindi non serve più
neanche questa televisione che troneggia
in un salotto
io ricordo i miei nonni ci facciano fare
la scena ci facciano la ridente ci
facciano vedere cervello è finito il
cartello se devo andare a letto ma ci
prima ci davano sempre un cioccolatino
una caramella mi sono sempre chiesta
perché dovevamo la precedenti prima però
insomma questo era nelle cose del
passato in cui si sarebbe tanto per
rimarcare sull'educazione di quei tempi
e oggi invece ognuno sta col proprio
device seduto dove vuole e in realtà
anche stanno insieme per ognuno guarda
quello che gli interessa
credo che anche i miei figli adesso
stiamo guardando infatti il cellulare
non qui pur essendo seduti là in fondo è
la generazione mettiamola così quindi
cambia la casa cambiano gli stili cambia
un po tutto
forse dovremo accettarlo non lo so è
però tutto questo comporta una modifica
abitativa e di stile di vita e quindi
una necessità di ridimensionare questi
spazi
sin dagli anni cinquanta si portano
avanti studi per creare case piccole per
rivedere quali possono essere gli
standard a cui riferirsi per l'abitare
qui l'avevate vista la casa è questa qui
è evidenziata in rosso è una casa
costruita nell'interstizio tra due
palazzi perché il principio fondamentale
non è solo quello di fare delle case più
piccole più adatte a questa demografia
che è fatta di piccole di poche persone
ma anche quella di recuperare
all'interno del tessuto consolidato
della città più spazi possibili perché
non si può più andare oltre alle città
non si può più in tessuto esterno
bisogna lasciarlo alla natura e
all'agricoltura e questa casa non
risponde a nessuno degli standard
abitativi in realtà prende
dall'abitacolo delle macchine la sua
sperimentazione è in realtà c'è la coda
per sperimentare uno stile di vita fatto
di dimensioni diverse
il giappone l'ha fatta da padrone nel
globo che possiamo trovare tantissime di
esempi di case realizzate in questo
senso che vanno appunto sempre in cerca
di spazi vuoti lasciati all'interno
delle città per poter creare nuovi nuovi
spazi per tutti e una di queste
soluzioni proprio quella di andare sopra
i tetti sopra i tetti delle case a
costruire piccoli alloggi per coppie per
single
però anche persone che abbiano fasce di
reddito diverse da quelle dell'edificio
consolidato del centro storico e che
possano quindi andare a creare un mix
sociale in più cellule autosufficienti
cellule che producono la loro energia e
quindi riescono in qualche modo a dare a
dare energia tutto l'edificio in cui si
insediano su questo anche renzo piano ho
fatto una ricerca è stata una ricerca
autonoma poi finanziata da vitra di un
piccolissimo alloggio completamente
autosufficiente di 2 m 42 m 40 per 2
metri e 90 insomma una scatoletta
piccolissima nella quale c'è tutto
cucina bagno soggiorno e camera da letto
che arriva assemblata in alien
dall'industria quindi arriva e si
installa nel punto in cui la mettiamo
con una roulotte sostanzialmente è
dotata di fotovoltaico e solare termico
produce la sua acqua calda e in realtà
raccoglie pure l'acqua piovana
questa piccolissima cellula la chiamata
diogene il nome ricordo del filosofo
greco che scelse di vivere in una botte
per dimenticare il lusso mondano
dell'abitare
già da allora e viveva solo con un
bastone un mantello e si riparava in
questa botte e aveva una ciotola con se
un giorno vide un fanciullo ragazzino
bene con le mani e allora buttò la
ciotola e gli disse ho imparato dai
bambini che sono gli unici esseri umani
non corrotti dalle convenzioni sociali e
quindi cerca validi trovare il messaggio
per vivere
in un modo più esistenziale e allora la
scelta di vivere così in realtà forse
non volutamente la fanno tante persone e
ritorniamo alla storia di nell'inizio
quella che chiameremo spin time che un
edificio dell'inpdap l'ex sede generale
a roma in centro storico un edificio di
12 mila metri quadri che è stato
occupato da 323 persone guidate da
tarzan uno dei capi del movimento per
l'occupazione e queste persone hanno
occupato questo edificio e hanno
restituito i suoi due piani terra sa
bene comune sono due piani terra in cui
si tengono conferenze a cui possono
partecipare tutti i cittadini romani ci
sono c'è la scuola di tango ci sono
laboratori di falegnameria e altre
attività che possono insegnare a tutti a
imparare un artigianato
c'è anche una palestra in questo luogo
negli uffici queste persone sono andate
ad abitare e ciascuno secondo i propri
stili di vita e secondo lei sulla sua
cultura ha riadattato questo spazio come
proprio a casa ma sono spazi nei quali
ovviamente essendo degli uffici non si
ritrovano tutte le cose che noi abbiamo
nelle case e quindi per esempio tutti i
corridoi sono diventati luogo comune
i soggiorni veri e proprio dove giocare
o dove stendere diventano gli spazi di
connessione e la stessa cosa dicasi per
le cucine l'acqua non arriva in tutti
gli uffici e quindi le cucine sono
comuni ugualmente i bagni ecco da questa
lezione io credo che noi possiamo
imparare due cose una che possiamo
ridimensionare lo spazio di cui abbiamo
bisogno perché effettivamente non
abbiamo bisogno di tutto quello che ci
portiamo dietro e 2 che possiamo oltre
che a ridimensionarlo anche condividerlo
qui potete vedere un esempio di in
giallo lo spazio privato ognuno la sua
camera da letto e in blu e verde gli
spazi comuni soggiorni le camere per gli
ospiti e le cucine e bagni tutto quello
che ci serve meno questo è uno stile di
vita che si può imparare perché in
effetti condividere significa anche
abbandonare quell idea del possesso
dell'oggetto un'evoluzione ci potrebbe
vedere per portarci a una riduzione
dello spazio autonomo individuale
persone
e a condividere tanti oggetti
sull'automobile lo conosciamo questo
questo concetto del car sharing è
abbastanza diffusa ormai e soprattutto
in città grandi come roma per esempio è
veramente ormai funzionante ed anche
molto più comodo ma questo vale per
mille oggetti quanti frullati ci
facciamo al mese
vogliamo il frullato il frullatore
quanti buchi nel muro ci servono e ci
serve il buco o il trapano e alla fine
quante camere per gli ospiti quanti
ospiti ospitiamo in realtà in un anno
quindi tutto questo sono dei beni di cui
dei quali noi ci dotiamo di cui non
avremmo bisogno
esistono anche delle cucine in cui si
può cucinare tutti insieme ormai è un
format abbastanza diffuso quindi
tendenzialmente la nostra casa potrebbe
cambiare molto
in più c'è un altro problema c'è un
problema di standard legislativi
pensate che se io ho un limite
costruttivo di 10 metri per un edificio
in italia siccome l'altezza interpiano
e2 m 70 posso fare tre piani in francia
ne posso fare 4 allora ci si come dire
schermisce alle accuse di questa di
questa differenza normativa del fatto
che l'italia un paese caldo e quindi un
volume d'aria maggiore consente di stare
meglio dare più benessere
io vi chiedo però tra genova e marsiglia
qual è la differenza di temperatura ecco
noi stiamo lavorando per ridefinire la
normativa che regola la casa per dare
una casa per tutti che sia ovviamente
che dia benessere ma che consenta a più
persone di poter stare nel nostro paese
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]